and beyond the arc is presented by
mountain America credit union yes Ngati
members forward now for more than 80
years luckily he got up no injury nice
feed inside the bear knocked it away in
the Jazz come the other way I just kind
of moans and groans with that 3:12 you
knew that he's not gonna sustain 65
percent from the three-point line go
faired connelly buns by go fair drives
pot fire Rudy three seconds on the shot
how much ground he covers Conley to the
rim Gobert says no no no not right now
[Applause]
Memphis will take the time out
Ricky stays on the hip of Hardin you
gotta be on that left side with hard
rock Gobert great tandem like they have
that one back it would have been this xx
point and a half it's almond Hill to
give blocks I go pair Oh baby Rudy jazz
was with 12 3/4 made 10 makes by
Minnesota Wiggins guys dental good for
everybody says get on out blocked shot
by coke there
this is a nice job I really go pay or
not that way defensively back out to
Smith drives by Ricky nice blocks block
by go bear active and swats little
nastiness for the Jazz on the teeth is a
ridiculous number not a huge sample size
yet but it's still a big number ASCO
bears and eyes brown we're Celtic go
bear too long to that Horford gets it
back and gets sold
- rim Gobert would have none of it
beerus giving him fits fill the shoulder
down lady stands his ground that's shot
get out of here Thabo - O'Neill who just
checked in
you're rolling inside for two Rudy
Gobert take on the challenge of indeed
you know he wants to go middle go up and
get that block shot Marcus Marcus got it
he's running towstee face don't care
get out fast break a B try to go coast
to coast you see Colbert there and
everyone's like alright go good luck I
mean this is what Gobert does get that
out of here the Jazz of God a final run
[ __ ] spins inside lady
it starts with defense Mike and here we
go Donovan in the paint slips and slides
selectively against these guys you get
the block by Gobert and that's an
opportunity when you take off go the
other direction
head over 4 points off the bench
he's got the rebound and running with a
b-bow threes made by
got back recovered somehow to get that
ball away from Collison riders stop and
go drive how about this block shot he
gets beat and then the recovery of
Gobert just gets fingers those are high
percentage shots you must make they are
especially coming out of the suit bowler
when it's when you're just starting the
game Gobert games of the season for
Royce he's in double digits for the
lovin that was started by Ricky Rubio
gets in the paint on the last couple of
times but really Gobert he's winking a
jazz nation he's back and he's healthy
28 points deep three taps go pair three
pound cut on Kimball Walker breaks loose
from Ricky Lee zip for zell a big man
rolls up the inside and go parents there
to knock it into the front row the
credit card comes out at 18 is that
right season-high three-point percentage
is 48 percent jazz might break then
sixty-one teen is the number that is a
season-high for three-point make Donovan
runs after Johnson takes on Gobert
reverse shot no ball comes loose
Mitchell has it not in movies house
that's what Lake City core / trailer
three play rebound Winslow
takes on go fair slides it up Rudi stays
with it Kim out a here here comes Ricky
magic control and grant sizing it up and
he has a lot to size up wits go pair
right on his tail could feel the
pressure behind him
Utah head by four bootchie bootch quiet
night thus far going over go bear he
wanted to go bear there for the block
Rubio sinking
talk to her from 23 feet that's his
third three-pointer that comes Harden
blocks by Gobert rarity you got your
credit card handy tonight that's 11
threes by Utah that Gobert same bike
ride and here comes clover the other way
to Joe
[Music]
Westbrook running downhill Adam spills
at Collins news tonight I go fair
Jae Crowder all the way inside without
the other
behind-the-back against Rubio trying to
go into Colbert worthless recovered it
chipped alive and clear by Utah you keep
going to it
des backed with its five will bear got a
piece great blog Clark sent up at eight
point half into paint again goes with
its right hand block by Colbert bagels
runs he's got Donovan on a wing pops up
at three up and yes we're Mitchell and a
22222 to run which is good block Gobert
this time gets be dumping gerbil but his
recovery is very good watch them go up
and get them walk fighting off the
bigger zobeir and again he shows that
explosiveness but Gobert sends it into
the seats
let's just Rudy Gobert locked needy just
dominate the hood takes a shot trying to
bank it home
scoop it won't go visit once twice fight
we go there
did not pull the trigger on the three
and said to goes inside great deep I
Crowder ripped it away Kirkuk block
Pikeville pear flavor the defense booty
picks up Damien's baseline to fill the
paint back up there at a jazz run with
Crowder pulled the trigger for three no
well it's a first and extra care was
taken to closer to capture that
let's see I taught you a little concern
a little nervous
there's Jarret Aeolus behind the back
pass Gipson spins on Gobert they'll go
up on under Rudy had nothing to do with
it block that shot out bounce pass
favors runs the floor down to the mid to
do the great thing I think the Jazz need
to do more up get the ball inside go
pair with another blocked shot two
tonight
Rudy right here really timing the ball
well knocking down a shot and just
talking smack to Ricky Rubio towns
blocked Gobert you see twice now that
explosive athleticism with that block
fight go bear Lily thought he had a
laugh but now Mitchell again explodes
into the front courts month why he
should be on the all-star team to give
you every argument why I still feel like
I should what beer must have heard yet
thank you
him for the year it goes off and gets
this one its effect on the game but the
smaller guy they bounce off this parter
inside block Gobert not tonight
he says - Alex Lynn corporate 3 got it
du Brey Buddy Walk do - got a piece you
pension here comes O'Neal
that's tomorrow - yeah when you grab the
rim and also you think you have a laugh
there's go very close to come do that um
they wanted Kyle to get a shot away they
absolutely did and you gotta watch out
for this this sperm lineup because they
surround DeRozan and Aldridge with three
really good three-point shooters this is
what makes the Jazz so great defensive
this is why you can overplay bowler on
the perimeter to get an errant crack
back shot clock at ten here's Schroder
driving
Gobert comes over and rejects it out of
play seven on the shot clock for Donovan
it just seems a common a common
occurrence nightly back there all the
young rookie blunts had got a a little
less in there for the big man Eagles
start to G Dunham oh yeah Rudi's just
baited Gallinari slips
and it's it's a pass inside tonight I'm
going for your box a lot of up and down
so far in this first half he goes trying
to channel Luther was right back there
picked up plenty of time bounce pass
inside quarter finished watch Paul
Millsap he's made back-to-back threes
here by Gobert oh that's beautiful
so it's either holiday gonna take both
their defense
hopefully we'll feed offense could get
there he's by him and look at Rudy
covered remember the pelicans ranked
number three in scoring t they go better
over 116 a night for the Jazz defense
number six in the league in scoring down
at 14 on the reset so birds on to go
over the screen parcel there's Crowder
hip hop by Rudy
here's shrewder inside the Morris
sawmill bear had nowhere to go
jazz have a chance to tie or take the
lead back as I drafted a Kogi he's a
defensive minded guy but maybe that's
what they're leaning toward he's
definitely the go-to guy up the pressure
and that's what they've done the last
four or five possessions here in Rudy
Gobert gets another block shot seam go
up times this one perfect got some fond
memories here - Utah - played here for
urine it's an 11 and 15 there's another
block though bear Rudy got a piece of it
love it Rubio set to check back in
coming the other way as the yang and a
quick pelvic deadly well you can
challenge it if you want to but not many
the climbed Everest very few but to
blocksberg ovett night done back inside
bear this first SWAT in two games deep
yeah trying to test that the waters
inside nice job i routed my throat Lopes
and rebounds and the Bulls run with gun
will drive it inside block bear three
[Applause]
and a 12-2 run
49:38 utah booker is eight straight run
sit inside the bear got a piece as black
[Applause]
go bear 164 swats angle three that's a
minute
nice defense a block here go bear
[Applause]
staggers stutter step thought he was
tripped we'll call bill runs against Joe
goes on the baseline marker against
Thabo drives inside routing maybe got a
hand up and a piece on it's ninety four
ninety topo runs over the top it goes to
Joe catching shoot three clutch the Jazz
18 of 18 from the line tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
slap and that's the guys everyone step
up play a little bit better than they
usually do Gobbo picked up by Donovan
nice pass down low block by Rudy and
also get it done with defense Gobert he
is so good is so good Joe taught history
look at go bear get up time it that's a
deadly shot 62 57
Joe going for a 20-point 919 I didn't
really think Ricky stopped this forward
progress as much as play good defense
[Music]
big man's there for another
yep against the sun's would be inside
draws the foul
I would box out he's gonna get a lot of
minutes here the second half ticket
rolling back back there and that ball
finds its way back to Caruso a four to
shoot down to three crosses over top
over I've psycho bear and a shot clock
violation Rousseau thinks he's got to
look at the layup and then out of
nowhere here comes Gobert blocks the
corner enjoying the spot-on pass as
another Mountain American credit union
3-point shot
digital adapter for the camp hunter at
Huntsman Cancer Institute which is over
three minutes to play
Plumlee takes it faces up Col Baird
what's a sure
[Applause]
he-ey Defensive Player of the Year come
on give it to him back-to-back hardened
runs down the rebound here come the
Rockets he told one trying to add to a
clock that Gobert
[Applause]
capella from smile to Gloucester go
there to nothing they've won games 1 and
2 by combined 52 points
[Applause]
David on the offensive boards getting
that extra possession
now the peaceful the mighty spray on the
floor and let this guy do what he does
best and that's black shot what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content